the Joe Rogan experience I can't believe
you didn't get the book I'm sorry I'm
gonna make sure you get it well there's
a there's a picture immediate Wow that
was from a newspaper article in my local
newspaper who and I think I was a
sophomore in high school and that was
the first time they called me Rick Baker
monster maker
yeah that was that's from high school
that was yeah I was think I was the
third and no I must have been like 14 or
15 or 16 something like wow man you were
committed to the path oh I mean my
bedroom had it was all masks and you
know the roar did you ever do the Aurora
model kits yes yeah yeah yeah I mean
that was one of the big regrets that oh
when I got married I thought well I got
it grow up yeah you know really models I
got rid of the models in uh I've
regretted it ever since those were so
cool you paint him I remember those I
think I had a I think I had a Creature
from the Black Lagoon one did they make
a creature yeah yeah yeah that was that
was an interesting film right because
that was a that was a unique turn-on
makeup where they took this guy and they
kind of put him in sort of like a scuba
suit slash reptilian thing that was one
of the cooler makeup works for the time
it still is it still the best man in the
sea yeah really well done
pull that up Jamie Creature from the
Black Lagoon that was like what was it
50s yeah and it that was the Westmore
regime Jack Pierce who did Frankenstein
the Wolfman all the classic stuff was
used old-school techniques during the
time when other people were doing foam
rubber and a new regime came in
Universal and all of a sudden Jack got a
pink slip you know you're you're out you
know these movies yeah very cool yeah go
go with the larger one in the lower left
corner Jamie what you see the whole body
yeah I mean what a cool design it is and
it was designed by a woman Millicent
Patrick who she nailed it she did but
she didn't get a lot of I mean Bud West
regime got the credit for but
when the movie came out with us on that
yeah when some publicist found out that
a woman designed it it was they did a
whole kind of Beauty and the Beast
campaign and apparently bud Westmore was
furious you know he goes it's my work
it's
and he was he was famous for posing with
other people's stuff you know I mean a
very fine sculptor named Chris Muller
sculpted the creatures head anyways and
I think he did the abdomen in some of
the parts and he also desculpe the metal
oni mutant from this island earth you
know that big bomb okay yeah and there's
a there's some pictures of Budd Westmore
holding a really inappropriate sculpture
tool next to the sculpture and from what
I heard he would
whenever the publicist would come to
take pictures he let give everybody a
day off or the afternoon off and then he
would go to the lab and pose what that
oh I hate here in story so disappointing
you know when you want to think that all
these people who take credit for all
that work they did the work yeah and I
tried to do that and it's funny because
you know so many people mean I never
wanted to be businessman you know and I
never even thought about that aspect of
it you know that I would have to have
employees and all that you know I mean
either and I hated that I didn't I mean
that was something I didn't care for you
know and I resisted being a businessman
I didn't have I wasn't listed anywhere
my company wasn't listed I didn't have a
letterhead I didn't have business cards
how the hell I don't didn't have an
agent you know how the hell I ever was
successful I don't know other than that
fact that I worked hard and my work was
pretty good you know yes fortunately I
don't work out for me like I said
certainly did
[Applause]